what was to you the biggest difference
between mixed martial arts and uh jiu
jitsu what are some interesting
differences some interesting insights
even just about the grappling within
both Sports
so the biggest difference for me
between MMA and Jujutsu is first is the
speed like Jiu Jitsu you know like a 10
minutes match I can take my time there's
no dangers that that forces me to move
fast
MMA you have to be 100 Sharp
in fast from
first second of the fight because
punches are coming you can get knocked
out anytime one mistake you're out do
you still don't have that like it's I
don't have to worry about quick
submissions because it's all about the
way my body is positioned you know my
grips it's easy to avoid it's easier to
see it coming
like it's like a quick submission a
surprise it only works if you make a
mistake if you're not correct
positioning otherwise it's impossible
it's extremely difficult MMA is not I
mean one Split Second mistake and when
the person comes
you have to respond you have to to match
your space I mean you can slow down but
it's like you you're forced to respond
so that much faster is that it's a lot
more physical a lot more
and you need to be physical much better
conditioning faster it's explosiveness
it's much harder is it possible in the
MMA to
calm things down unless if they change
the rules yeah five minute rules now
ah I see so like um I I just meant
actually technically speaking is there
ways to
to take an opponent that's being
exceptionally aggressive you can clinch
clinch but then he takes her down he
keeps moving so I'm saying it's hard to
control that pace
you can you don't if you play defense
you'll you save more energy than if you
try to beat aggressor and respond
and even getting to the clinch is very
difficult yeah you have no way to hold
yourself there so that was the biggest
challenge for me in MMA is the speed
because I'm a very slow start fighter if
you look at my matches I start very slow
because if I go hard you know I fatigue
faster
so for me that was the hardest part
of is to start fast
what about on the ground is there
something different
more challenging on the ground being in
the bottom yes the sponges yeah how
fundamentally different is Jiu-Jitsu
punches on the ground that changes
everything everything
which which parts the the distance that
you allow your opponent to be on you the
techniques that you choose to apply
you know you you have to
but your body has to be aware of the
punches and you know you are a lot more
limited on your attacks like so you're
you're known for your closed guards how
does your closed guard have to adjust
how does the positioning of your hands
have to adjust when you're on the bottom
of close guard so in the guide
especially in the close guard you you
have to either keep the person very
close to you or you have to kick him
away that's in the guard is either I'm
hugging you or get away from energy
Jitsu you're allowed to have a middle
yeah there's a lot of you can allow the
person to be
what about getting a a arm lock or a
triangle submissions from the from the
guard is is that fundamentally different
because you don't have the middle game
is much harder
there's barely no open guard
in MMA very little
because the open guard there's a
distance between you and him yeah
there's a decency how you you cannot
control it's much harder to control that
punch coming and I have to position
myself a way to block that and it
limited my attacks my options of attacks
is there a reason
correct me if I'm wrong but I don't
think you do open guard much in Jiu
Jitsu and nogi
is there a reason for that
it's harder with the explosive uh
explosive person
because it's you know when they're
moving fast then you have to try to slow
them down so you like guards that allow
you to control the person
and closed guard is the ultimate control
oh no it's not ultimate control but
close guy puts in a position that I'm
attacking in your defending you cannot
attack me for my close guard
we can argue that those might be one or
two attacks but it's like
very very very limited and
depends who you're fighting against
I I hate the Coast Guard of being on top
well against a good close guard is no
one likes this is terrible it's horrible
yeah it's one-sided yeah so even the
garden is one-sided the person the
brother has the advantage I can be
completely relaxed in my closed guard
and I cannot be completely relaxed not
the most annoying thing is is somebody
who is both good and extremely confident
with a close card because they have that
smug energy about them they know how
much unpleasant how much work it takes
to pass this anyway
um especially people with longer legs
is there something you um wish you did
differently in how you started trading
at MMA in that trajectory and figuring
out how to train how to get good like
what have you learned about getting good
at MMA
from having done it if you were to start
now for example
I think I would have to dedicate it more
I didn't dedicate enough
uh both like literally time number of
training sessions training yeah but also
mental training wise physique yeah I
think a lot more the physical part of it
the strikes everything the strike from
the beginning it's
because
I mean not a lot of Jujutsu like it's I
truly love the all deaths backs of it
fighting training you know the practice
the competition
I don't have that for MMA so it's hard
to to give your heart to it something
that you don't have the passion to it
like Jiu Jitsu you know I gave my heart
to it like I did everything that I had
to MMA I never I didn't do that so
that's why it was
I won't say it was wrong for me to to
have to to do it because I don't regret
doing I always
you know looking back as a kid when I
decided to you know to be
to take Jiu Jitsu for life I I already
knew that some point I would have to do
MMA there's almost like that's the path
of a Gracie you know you when you're
ready you go to MMA
so there was a like a Duty versus a love
yeah that was that was not a choice that
was like I have to
that's just the the life I took he will
lead that way
are you proud of that stuff you know go
against the natural love and towards
more Duty
I think
I don't regret it because if I hadn't
done it I would feel there was something
missing yeah so I don't regret doing I
would regret not doing
the the tricky thing is the choice to go
to MMA
could have compromised your ability to
win against Patricia
and it didn't and it's um it's a
fascinating
case study it still doesn't make sense
to me they after all those years you're
able to come back and go against the
best person in the world and beat him
yeah
and I had to because the first fight we
had
I had something stuck in my throat for a
long time
you think so you think about that oh
yeah I'm like as soon as that first
fight finished
a headset I that got stuck in my throat
that I already at that point I knew I'm
gonna have to fight him again I knew
I always knew
because there's no choice I have to